you probably heard about this story it's
kind of silly but apparently there's a
cat in England have you heard about this
cat it's had a lot of trouble being
adopted no one wants to adopt this cat
because it looks like Hitler there's the
cat this is a true story the cat looks
like Hitler show them again the cat
looks exactly like that and nobody wants
to adopt the cat well I looked into it
because I felt bad it turns out there
are a lot of animals out there that are
not getting adopted because of their
unfortunate resemblance to certain
famous people or something unpleasant
about them it's true there's a cat with
a Mike Tyson tattoo that nobody wants
yeah there's that this is too bad
there's a dog that looks like Kim
jong-il take the glasses I don't help
you'll get adopted this is too bad there
this is too bad there's a cat that
reminds people of Snooki from Jersey
Shore
again go back that's really stupid
there's a dog no one wants with the
words free oj on it that's too bad yeah
that's just then that is an unfortunate
birthmark and finally here's a dog that
looks like Moammar Ghadafi and nobody
[Applause]